ltd ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fatti j
oggi siamo tornati su dune da un pezzo
lo sappiamo fuori fuori porta
e morta così ragazzina non è morta nel
morto una sega quindi vediamo di colori
morire
non so se hai capito ma devi morire e
devi morire anna che cazzo queste
pubblicate su facebook senza trucco
senza niente di come muore travasato i
testicoli st pizarro 8 veramente le
spalle in maniera più incredibile
tartassarli meghni maroni perchè giuro
ti faccio un culo che non nei derby mi
sono chiuso pure dentro amico aveva
fatto a cazzotti come un porco lì prima
però cinghiale di 12 metri di prima per
il problema è che non ha lasciato nulla
è stato quando ci sono ancora passata
alla figlia devi morire razza di shrek
geneticamente modificato
marie fuoristrada un mare che mi
ricordavo che fu si moriva nella drag
iniqua non scappare lurido ma dove vai
morte doveva cucina di se non ha le
chiavi i fumi dove stendardo perché
azzannato legale sparito ma è difficile
nascondere un ciglio
ecco perché veramente difficile samson
da un cinghiale di 800 kg merda mi ha
preso in pieno perfetto poi così sorridi
che la mettiamo su facebook è bellissima
non sei un fantasma su vero ma perché ti
schiaccia sono un perfetto ragazzino lo
schiaccia non lo schiaccia lo spinge
bellissimi che lasciava dietro i ragazzi
tramite un bong vedo qualcosa dietro
armadio bellissimo una scrivania
faticaccia c'è qua dentro aver minato
vorrei a chiedevo cosa guarda che
vengono ancora capito perché se vado di
qua che la stanza di fianco della roba
rossa cesta cosa e non l'ho capito
ancora e bellissimo ragazzo in progetti
che si tiene per mano questo ma è un
caso oppure sono io che prima non erano
casuali allora cui cosi 9 c'erano dei
dei tizi che si tenevano per mano fatto
una foto bellissima gatto lo vuoi vedere
anche bellissima su 85 cosa di strani st
foto cosa cosa c'è di strano in una foto
legge sarà mica ci sono delle persone ha
prese a caso non no vabbè allora non so
se hanno preso della gente pa dei
lampadari
che cosa del genere non lo so per
ascendere chiaro no ragazze funziona con
un genio che ha parimenti ragazzi quella
era la stanza del cinghiale lo
riconoscete avrei sono stato mezz'ora
aridaje stati aridaje un cazzo il mio
obiettivo non era quello di prendere
infarti questo è sicuro bene tana [ __ ]
anno scende le scale quando è pigra
pigra meno male che è pigra sono ai
ragazzi ai miei sono sì numeri sui
banchi che si se piove piccola a caso ha
già sofia il migliore adesso sanno che
chi ha il migliore era il cazzo via
migliore trek di lordi la media migliore
c'è un tizio dietro di te non so se ne
sia accorto
ed è anche molto incazzato vedo al fermo
a [ __ ] mia mi ha oltrepassato di
brutto perfetto trovato la chiave
dell'armadietto credo sia quella quindi
di torno indietro ci metterò mezz'ora
quindi hai rotto le fa basta seguirmi
affanculo comedy della basta io ci sono
i sto falsi ci sono solo gli
effettivamente poi non puoi rompere il
cazzo ad altri lo ha ragione però il
problema è che ti chiudo fuori stronza
adesso non dovrebbe più rompere le palle
credo cioè meno almeno qui ma che sia
questa la chiave si si
mio dio 40 minuti è che infatti l'ha
vista qualcosa qua dietro prima di
fermat entra in l'armadio adesso è
aperto ma che non è un armadio e una
stanza segreta una scrivania temi capire
ma perché c'è un centro cosmetici in una
scuola dietro un armadio a caso e hanno
chiuso dentro lunedì a gatto a gatto
sono qua dentro mi apre a porta per
cortesia novabell asham perni hanno
chiuso letteralmente dentro essa è stato
il gatto secondo me stava complottando
sin dall'inizio se c'è una bambola con
bambini ma è vivo non nemico e una
bambola credo cosa fa
prima zia amica mia c'è qualcuno ferma
un attimo non so perché c'è un finto c'è
una bambola credo non è una favola
ok per noi non è una bambola per niente
una spuntatina ma solo dietro è proprio
davanti il succo lo voglio come prima mi
faccia 5 euro una spuntatina dietro e
poi la permanenza e se rimane tempo non
ho grazie progetto facciamo chiusi che
anche al mio parrucchiere che è meglio
che i ragazzi c'è una tizia senti è
sparita a caso sento ai quattro fette
sisti e trasporta tipo ora ma giuro
amica mia centro cazzo ma ogni volta la
perdo ma perche sono dal parrucchiere
scusatemi øer in una scuola [ __ ] che
begli occhi che ai profondi mimì mi sono
innamorato letteralmente faccia che sia
una parrucchiera ma cazzo ma infatti i
capelli almeno c'è una casa ha tentato
di tango su facebook sono cazzi tuoi poi
raga io io io faccio un album poi
elemento tutte ste foto se sappiatelo
garmin attimo regala ecco [ __ ] ho
vinto sì lurida stronza il taglio me lo
fai la prossima volta
era costava troppo per quelle brava
brava eccola lì per così impari a a fare
la permanenza 10 euro non ha non ha
senso sta cosa manipal ma quanto è bello
sto bambino a parte tutto dato mi guarda
con una faccia come dire con premi dei
nuovi giocattoli sentite ma penso che
tutti sono venute le forbici le prendo a
si possono prendere un paio di forbici
rinvenute nell'infermeria è un
infermeria questa no io pensavo fossi la
tua rocchiero è più o meno la stessa
cosa rito cinghia fantastico regalo
quassù sta dormendo
scusami amico mio ci siamo ragazzi ci
siamo aspetta aspetta un attimo però
sorride ecco è questa la maglia ma la
mamma dammi le chiavi perché mi servono
e mezza dall'inizio del gioco che ci
accosta cazzo di chiavi già impossibile
la forbice che cosa serviva di preciso a
tagliare le chiavi che domande perché
già impossibile capire quello che ho
fatto
cos'è che c'è se mai ci sono messi
davanti alla porta da soli fantastico
della roba che ha bloccato la porta non
so se è normale tutto questo ma non
importa noi facciamo il giro ma che è
meglio a chiunque abbia tirato l'armadio
mica se mi prendeva le mazzate che gli
arrivavano a rega non so chi è chi è che
sta tentando di uccidermi ma devo
tornare alla sala principale
ma che cazzo libico si ride stati
pannoso va beh a parte che ci sono degli
dei moscerini che bloccano l'uscita ma
se l'esempio di fatto si tolgono ac
posso passare in mezzo la fantastica
vero che serve un merda rega no no no
via via pussa via usato ma era così
lungo sto corridoio la prima volta
buongiorno regala bargecchia tso sta
succedendo pregare che una porta a casa
una porta a caso grazie merda
ok sei bellissima sei veramente
bellissimo questo volevo dire conosco un
parrucchiere che cosa può che cosa vuoi
non so che cosa è successo sono morto
veli a questa questa è proprio la parte
del gioco morire o sono morto un
riquadro rosso indica che un'entità
sovrannaturale vicina al quale riquadro
rosso scusami si sa son tornato al suo
tornato vivo perfetto sa se apre una
porta e mi ci infilo dentro madonna che
è bello che è qua dentro c'è qualcosa da
fotografare che tipo non vedo non lo so
ok
sì c'è una porta c'è una porta c'è una
porta a caso qua in mezzo non so perché
la apro qua si ha chiara caso ho trovato
una porta in un muro per il bellissimo
se votassi diomio non so come ho fatto
regala oggi usciamo ragazzi chi cazzo è
stati si sa di preciso ok devi morire
davanti se c'è una cosa che non riesco a
capire insieme non si può uscire lo
stesso
mio dio ma quando fai schifo senti ho
capito che sei a dieta proprio fare
anche dei cioè non è che devi essere
così rigorosa l'altra tutte le cose
poteva proporre un charm il insetti cus
e chi no [ __ ] muori muori ragazzi
sono incastrato merda sei stronzo non ho
mai ucciso non è ucciso ok ragazzi sono
ma che cazzo ci faccio lo ripicca
all'apporto scommetto domando ricco si
sono rifatta smettila di mangiarlo
schifosa ripensateci andavano meglio di
sette cazzo perché mi ha lanciato un
topo il prossimo al gatto sono convinto
sto troppo di mazzoli che l'ha invece di
fare così come una deficiente non solo
toglie di mezzo o no no mezz'ora per
arrivare qui non ho nomi non mi toccare
lurida non mi toccare verve artico mesi
cliccate o cliccata pochi cup
perfetto allora io non so chi tu sia ma
mi stai altamente sulle chiappe faccio
una foto la metto su come fare sparita
poiché tutte le donne scompaiono quando
li faccio foto non lo so e ragazzi
usciamo uniqua perché non si può aprire
la porta finalmente non si può aprire
cos'è cosa c'è ancora non c'è un botto
combattuto contro insetti topi e forse
gatti successo
la sa cos'è sta roba non mio dio ho
finito fantastico ragazzi ho finito il
primo capitolo di tre d'auto è stato
strano ringrazio dio che comunque non si
è mangiata al gatto perché più poco ci
mancava comunque va beh meglio così lo
continuerò comunque quando uscirai
capitolo dopo perché sono curioso di
vedere che cosa si mangiano gli altri
animali e video è piaciuto a sotto un
commento mi piace anche a pagliari
facebook e come non i video trovata la
descrizione se non se ne feriti discrete
noi ci mettiamo nel prossimo video bene
ragazzi